All right, let's see how we did.
If you checked record ID, weather
condition ID, minimum temperature,
wind speed, humidity,
maximum temperature,
date, weather direction and
pressure, you've got this right.
Now technically,
one could have included either date or
time, as time includes date.
Month doesn't really
make any sense here.
But since we're really displaying the
date, it makes sense for the database to
actually replicate what's on
the display as much as possible.
Units should be stored in
a separate table with preferences.
There's no reason to store things
we aren't displaying, such as,
you know, rainfall or
average temperature.
And besides, we cannot get these
from the OpenWeatherMap API.
We do need weather condition ID,
since we use this to
both display the forecast, and
determine the image to display.
And finally,
while it's not displayed in our UI,
we need an ID column to
uniquely identify each row.
As discussed, it's required for
all SQLI database tables that are going
to be displayed in Android list views.